the commotion
and congestion which colors life in
lagos
has now disappeared the gangs with
knives and sticks are out blocking roads
on the outskirts of town and demanding
cash
for free passage
agitators have burnt buildings and
looted shops
as a two-week street protest in nigeria
focused on a much despised police unit
has turned into something else something
more sinister
the process was good to show
being enjoyed by the good luck like what
is on there man look at this pool now
blocking the road
collecting money what's it for
the city's 15 million residents are
supposed to stay at home
there's a strict curfew in place but the
government
has damaged its relationship with many
citizens
on tuesday members of the security
services opened fire on youthful
protesters
calling for an end to police brutality
amnesty international says at least 12
people were killed
however the president of nigeria didn't
mention the shootings
in this plea for calm your voice
has been hard loud and clear
and we are responding
president buhari called on protesters to
get off the streets
and warned of subversive elements now
threatening
national security but that's upset
prominent nigerians now clamoring for
fundamental change
okay how are you doing john yeah very
well thanks we spoke exclusively
to burna boy he's one of the world's
most popular music artists
the government the military they want
the protesters
off the streets they've said look we've
we've met your demands it's time to go
home
they've said that before haven't they
they've said that twice or three
times haven't they
so what makes this time different so we
should go everybody should go home
because
you say it again
show me and so far you've showed me his
blood of my people
so what are you telling me he says a new
generation
the liberation generation are trying to
hold the political elite to account
something that's never happened in
nigeria before
this is the most important moment in
nigeria's history
the most by far important moment of
nigeria's history
that's what we're witnessing right now
you know because
if if nothing changes after this if
if this doesn't work then you know
it's over
the protesters have unleashed long
simmering forces
and their leaderless movement and
nigeria's politicians
may end up struggling to control it john
sparks
sky news